усе може закінчитися цього року якщо
адміністрація США скаже що ми хочемо
Перемоги України Якби у них вже були
атакам з на 300 кілометрів вони б уже
могли зробити так щоб Чорноморський флот
залишив Севастополь тому що це 300 км Я
думаю що у них набагато більше
бронетанкових бригад ніж ми знаємо
український генштаб Краще за нас
справляється із захистом інформації ви
можете вбити кожного російського солдата
в радіусі 200 км від бахмута і це не
змінило б стратегічної ситуації але якщо
ви звільняєте Крим - це змінює все
дякую що прийшли в студію генерали
ходжес Отже ми всі бачили яка ситуація
нині в бахмуті зважаючи на ваш
військовий досвід коли ви дивитесь на те
якими там стали бої дехто проводить
паралелі з Першої Світової війною ви
були здивовані тим що це переросло в
таку похмуру картину війни
[музика]
Мене дивує те як росіяни продовжують
кидати людей у цю м'ясорубку яка не має
для них очевидного стратегічного чи
навіть оперативного значення
Бахмут важливий не тому що це Бахмут а
тому що він дозволив українському
генштабу виграти час щоб підготуватися
до контрнаступу який я думаю відбудеться
через місяць-2
тож росіяни зв'язали їх продовжуючи
вводити туди війська і українці Я думаю
кілька місяців тому зрозуміли що вони
ймовірно можуть їх зупинити не
відволікаючи бронетанкові сили необхідні
для контрнасту
тож коли ви можете дещо відсторонитися
від цього і не думати про те що
відбувається на кожній з цих жахливих
вулиць про ці руйнування які ми
спостерігаємо щодня
відсторонитися від цього то насправді Це
добре для українського генштабу що вони
змогли зупинити там російські сили та
гербина
з українського боку кажуть що втрачено
багато людей я маю на увазі це технічне
слово яке використовується виснаження
але це все люди вони також втратили там
людей ви вважаєте що зважаючи на цілі
планування це була прийнятна втрата
знову ж таки якщо ви уважно подивитеся
на те що тут поставлено на карту Україна
бореться за своє життя І я думаю що
український генштаб знає що Крим я
вирішальним тереном цієї війни і Україна
ніколи не буде в безпеці доки Крим
окупований Росією Україна ніколи не
зможе відновити свою економіку доки Крим
окупований Росією і заблоковано доступ
до Азовського моря та до всіх пор на
Чорному морі Отже український генштаб
зрозумів що їм потрібно повернути Крим Я
думаю що вони мають намір повернути його
цього року і щоб це зрозуміти ви маєте
спочатку його ізолювати а потім задіяти
високоточні можливості ракет великої
дальності які можуть вразити Севастополь
авіабазу в Саках
логістичний центр у Джанкої та інші
об'єкти на Кримському півострові щоб
зробити їх неспроможними Ви можете вбити
кожного російського солдата в радіусі
двохсот кілометрів від бахмута і це не
змінило б стратегічної ситуації але якщо
ви звільняєте Крим - це змінює все тому
я думаю генштаб зрозумів що вони здатні
Я маю на увазі Що росіяни не захопили
Бахмут за 9 місяців і я думаю що в
генштабі це зрозуміли на кшталт Гаразд
Ми збираємося розмістити Тут те що маємо
що по довгостроковій перспективі ми
змогли досягти вирішального ефекту
закінчення цієї війни Отже Це довго
відповідь перше запитання чи прийнятно
це звичайно кожне життя має значення
Вони люди але вони і солдати така
природа війни і вони там виконують
завдання яке призведе до вирішального
результату для України
Тож давайте тепер якось поєднаємо ці
речі ви кажете що Крим насправді є
кінцевою метою Як ви сказали ми очікуємо
що цей Контрнаступ почнеться в найближчі
місяць або два Чого ви очікуєте які
кроки якщо Крим є метою які кроки ви
очікуєте зробить Україна у перші дні
цього контрасту
отже як ви знаєте це вже кілька місяців
називають весняним контрнаступком не
знаю чому люди називають це весняним
Контрнаступ Я взагалі не думаю що це
буде весняний Контрнаступ тому що земля
все ще багнюка і якщо ви починаєте
броньовану атаку ви очевидно хотіли б
мати найкращі можливі умови для
транспортних можливостей крім того
генштабу також Потрібен був час щоб
підготувати ці бронетанкові бригади Я
думаю що у них набагато більше
бронетанкових бригад ніж ми знаємо
український генштаб Краще за нас
справляється із захистом інформації
очевидно У них є багато власних Танків і
бронетехніки А також те що вони захопили
в росіян і тепер плюс те що ми захід
надаємо від німецького бундесверу
Великобританії США і так далі
вони тренувалися і відпрацьовували як
пробивати російську оборону лінії окопів
перешкоди міні поля так звані зуби
дракона і тому подібне
Я думаю що коли вони будуть готові коли
будуть створені умови це навчання з
проходження
логістика на місці Коли все буде на
місці тоді вони виберуть одне-два чи три
місця на фронті завдовжки 900 км Вони
збираються вибрати 2-3 місця в масовій
переважаючій бойовій потужності щоб
прорвати дістатися аж до Азовського моря
зламати так званий сухопутний міст який
з'єднує Крим з Росією
думаю Керченський міст залишать на
деякий час щоб росіяни які хочуть піти
могли піти але в якийсь момент звичайно
Коли все буде зроблено вони зруйнують
міст але наразі важливо ізолювати Крим
зламавши наземне міст Я вважаю що це
мета цього контрнаступу
тепер як це виглядає це буде
загальновійськова операція з танками
механізованою піхотою інженерними
підрозділами необхідними для розчищення
шляху артилерією здатною рухатися та
фокусуватися щоб захистити цей прорив
ширина якого може бути лише 10 або 20
кілометрів і Українські
військово-повітряні сили які звичайно
дуже поступалися в чисельності від
самого початку але при цьому росіяни
ніколи так і не змогли отримати перевагу
в повітрі що я думаю є відображенням не
лише математики але і їхніх професійних
можливостей
тож я очікую що українські військові
уповітрені сили відіграватимуть ключову
роль Протягом наступних кількох тижнів
переслідуючи російські артилерійський
штаби системи протиповітряної оборони
щоб допомогти здійснити Контрнаступ Отже
це буде спільна комбінована Атака
зосереджена на вузькій ділянці а потім
вони розвиватимуть прорив на основі того
де досягнуть успіху і будуть зміцнювати
успіх
ви говорите про прорив тип оборони який
матимуть росіяни тому що вони також мали
час на те що покупатися щоб створити
лінії оборони Є таке поняття окупної
війни захисної опишіть тип оборони який
українцям потрібно буде подолати як їм
це потрібно буде зробити
ваші глядачів вже бачили ці відео з
окопами фотографії супутникові знімки
опів та зубів дракона і таке інше тож я
не хочу нехтувати цим це буде фізично
важко і небезпечно і це глибока оборона
потенційно залежно від того де українці
вирішать атакувати
Звичайно вони повинні перетнути річку
Дніпро що є ще однією причиною коли ви
хочете зробити це якомога простішим з
точки зору часу
перетнувши річку Потім вони зіткнуться
змінними полями зубами дракона які є
бетонами перешкодами у формі піраміди а
потім будуть окопи з російськими
військовими в цих окопах та за старими
танками старої протитанковою зброєю яку
підтягнули І яка може стріляти вони не
повинні рухатися і ще можуть стріляти
тож буде товстий шар оборони який
українцям доведеться пробивати
це буде 2-3 шари і звісно росіяни якщо
вони й достатньо професійні вони
запланують артилерію коли Українські
сили наступатимуть ось через що
доведеться пройти українцям Очевидно
вони мають гарну розвідку і добре знають
що там відбувається Я маю на увазі ви
можете це побачити нічого з цього не
приховують
Тож вони я сподіваюся створять моделі
всього цього І кожен буде виконувати
свою роль
зробили це місяцями і вони будуть робити
це місяцями
ви кажете що мета дістатися до
Азовського моря через Крим Я маю на
увазі що є різні Думки щодо ролі Криму є
занепокоєння у деяких колах що якщо
Україна розпочне справжню атаку на Крим
це буде один із моментів коли Путін
потенційно витягне ядерну карту Яка ваша
думка щодо цього І що буде якщо вони
досягнуть цієї стадії Азовське море що
вони роблять далі чи це момент з якого
почнуть домовлятися момент коли відчують
що Володимир Путін вже у такому стані
коли він настільки ослаблений що Україна
має достатньо сильну позицію для
переговорів Розкажіть мені про сценарій
та про те чого ви очікуєте
Отже Україна ніколи не буде безпеці доки
Крим окупований Росією Вони завжди
зможуть здійснити наступну атаку чи то
через два три чи чотири роки тому якщо в
переговорах залишають Росію контроль над
Кримом автоматично Росія має величезну
перевагу Чорноморський флоту Севастополі
звідти діють військово-повітряні сили
логістика працює звідти тож з точки зору
безпеки вони повинні отримати Крим з
точки зору економіки економіка України
базується на експорті зерна та
рідкоземельних порід тож навіть якщо
Бердянськ і Маріуполь два великі порти
на Азовському морі були б звільнені або
росіяни залишили їх повернувши їх У
рамках переговорів українці ніколи не
зможуть з цим нічого зробити тому що
Крим досі блокує доступ до Азовського
моря та вихід з нього і звісно Одеса
знаходиться лише за 300 кілометрів від
Севастополя по прямій лінії тому
російському чорноморському флоту легко
продовжувати там торгувати коли Росія
заманеться як вона це робить зараз
Україна не зможе експортувати зерно без
дозволу Росії тому ідею про те що
якимось чином це буде прийнятний
результат для України Я вважаю смішною
ви порушили слушну тезу що люди
стурбовані це відомо що Крим є чимось
особливим для Путіна його репутації і
так далі я вважаю вкрай вкрай
малоймовірним що Росія застосує ядерну
зброю їхня ядерна зброя справді
ефективно лише тоді коли вони її
використовують тому що Ми продовжуємо
стримувати себе ніби О Боже мій вони
можуть застосувати ядерну зброю
Подивіться як ми всі відреагували або
оскільки людей відреагували коли вони
оголосили що відправляють тактичну
ядерну зброю Білорусь Я маю на увазі що
про це писали в пресі кілька днів це не
вплинуло на здатність Росії
використовувати цю ядерну зброю Це був
лише спосіб нагадати нам о у нас є я
зброя тому що вони знають як ми надмірно
реагуємо на це і я думаю що українці
якщо по них вдарять якщо Росія застосує
проти них тактично ядерну зброю десь в
Україні то українці не зупиняться вони
продовжуватимуть воювати і я думаю що
російський генштаб це знає ми
використаємо ядерну зброю Українці
продовжують воювати Що далі Мій
президент сказав що Росія матиме
катастрофічні наслідки якщо вона
застосує ядерну зброю президент сі
сказав не використовувати ядерну зброю
Індія сказала не використовувати ядерну
зброю тож я думаю що люди в оточенні
Путіна також знають що якщо після цього
має бути життя для них він не може
застосувати ядерну зброю
Отже Володимир Путін ми пропускаємо що
його найвищим інтересом є виживання
режими ніщо не перевершує це і
занепокоєння полягає в тому що якщо я
саме його виживання виживання його
режиму поставлено на карту тоді він бере
ядерну карту і пов'язує це у своїй
свідомості потенційно з Кримом по суті
ви розраховуєте На те що люди навколо
нього скажуть Вибачте ми не підемо цим
шляхом
сова
Насправді Я б сказав що виживання його
режиму не залежить від Криму Це залежить
від того чи зможе він захистити себе і
звичайно це буде принизливо але я не
думаю що він римський імператор Нерон
який готовий спалити усе навколо себе
він хоче переконатися що цього не
станеться що його не протягнуть через
Червону площу що його не спіткатиме доля
Каддафі чи садама Хусейна чи щось
подібне це тип який сидів за
десятиметровим столом щоб уникнути
зараження ковідом Я думаю що насправді
набагато раціональніший ми просто
переконали себе О Боже мій він може
використати ядерну зброю Я вважаю що це
безпідставно і я говорю про білий дім а
також про багатьох інших європейців про
тих хто насправді відчуває ефект від
цього найбільше українці як інші
східноєвропейці бояться цього набагато
менше ніж ті з нас Хто живе набагато
далі від нього
Отже ви намалювали доволі позитивну
картину того чого українці можуть
досягти за наступні кілька місяців але
все ще є занепокоєння з приводу того що
українці не мають достатньої підтримки у
вигляді зброї необхідної для цього чи є
у них те що їм потрібно те що ви
описуєте Чи їм вже бракує речей які їм
знадобляться для виконання того що ви
описали
потрібні дві речі по-перше їм потрібно
щоб президент Сполучених Штатів
німецький бундесканцлер прем'єр-міністр
Великобританії президент Франції сказали
що ми хочемо щоб Україна перемогла Немає
чіткого стратегічного результату
викладеного лідерами заходу ми не
говорили що хочемо щоб вони виграли ми
сказали що ми з вами стільки скільки
потрібно що я абсолютно безглуздим
твердженням або ми говорили що хочемо
щоб Росія програла і тоді ви почуєте як
хтось каже ну вони вже стратегічно
програли тому в Україні нічого з цього
не допомагає тож Мій президент має
сказати що наш бажаний стратегічний
результат такий-то вони цього не роблять
і я думаю це тому що вони стурбовані і
застосуванням ядерної зброї Я думаю що
Китай певну роль у цьому відіграє Я
думаю що люди з білого дому - це не
звучить правильно але вони майже бояться
Перемоги наприклад що буде якщо Україна
переможе вони не можуть цього
контролювати тож це потрібно Україні і
друге що їм потрібно з точки зору
фактичних можливостей це високоточна
зброя великої дальності здатність
вражати ці місця в Криму Якби у них вже
були атакам на 300 км вони б уже могли
зробити так щоб Чорноморський флот
залишив Севастополь тому що це 300 км а
Чорноморський флот важливий лише тому що
він може запускати крилаті ракети по
цивільних цілях Україна виграє цю справу
швидкість з якою це станеться залежить
від нас
Україна має витривалість щоб
продовжувати це потенційно руками якщо
ми подивимося на політичну ситуацію в
США то важко дивлячись на майбутнє
вибори та позиціонування там деяких
кандидатів думати що США збирається
збільшити свою підтримку в майбутньому
Можливо ми вже досягли стелі Я думаю Вам
слід запитати чи вистачає росіянам
витривалості що продовжувати Я не
впевнений що так немає охочих вступати в
російсь в армію ніхто не хоче росіяни не
хочуть їхати в Україну тому що вони
бачать що там відбувається їм доводиться
робити всілякі речі щоб поповнити свої
Лави людьми та відправити в цю
м'ясорубку немає ніякого ентузіазму бути
там з іншого боку Україна захищає свою
державу Вони борються за своє виживання
і тому з історії ми знаємо що війна - це
випробовування волі очевидно що в
українських солдатів і українського
народу набагато більше волі ніж у
російських солдатів і російського народу
російська оборона промисловість
розвалина вони явно не мають можливості
продовжувати надавати нескінченну
кількість речей тому Вони звертаються до
Ірану за безпілотниками Я маю на увазі
що це говорить вам про оборону
промисловість Росії і вони сподіваються
що Китай якось знайде способи їх
підтримати Але я думаю що Китайці дуже
неохоче роблять це тому що вони не
хочуть санкції які настануть у цьому
випадку тож я хотів би відповісти на
ваше конкре вони занепокоєння словами
сенатора мітча макконелла він був на
мюнхенській конференції з безпеки в
лютому підвівся і сказав Я тут із
величезною республіканською делегацією
щоб нагадати всім що Сполучені Штати
включаючи керівництво республіканської
партії піклуються про Європу НАТО та
Україну Ось чому ми тут Нехай вас не
бентежить кілька крикунів яких Ви чуєте
в крайньому правому крилі кілька
крикунів мається на увазі Дональд Трамп
Дональд Трамп не буде наступним
президентом
а як щодо його найбільшого суперника
губернатор десантіс вірно і що він
зробив коли губернатор десантів зробив
цей ідіотський коментар що це якась
регіональна прикордонна суперечка його
розтрощили республіканці які сказали що
ти ідіоти поняття не маєш про що говориш
Я більш ніж впевнений що конгрес США у
двопартійний спосіб буде продовжувати
підтримку України але це не повинно
тривати роками усе може закінчитися
цього року якщо адміністрація США скаже
що ми хочемо Перемоги України Ця війна
триває з 2014 року Росія все ще
контролює лише близько 15% України 9
місяців у бахмуті і вони ще не захопили
його з усіма своїми перевагами Вони все
ще не мають переваги в повітрі Вони досі
не запровадили цілісну командну
структуру Чорноморський флот нічого не
робить крім ракетних ударів по нерухомих
цілях багатоквартирних будинках росіяни
не змогли знищити одного потягу чи
колони з технікою та боєприпасами з
Польщі Як це за 14 місяців вони не
змогли вони не мають можливості знищити
один потяг тож за всіма показниками які
я бачу єдина перевага яку вони мають
полягає у тому що вони готові витратити
десятки тисяч життів штовхаючи їх у
м'ясорубку і це
нестабільном
Пане ходжес дякую за розмову з нами Отже
ми повернемося до вас Протягом наступних
кількох місяців і подивимося розкажете
мені як я помилявся дякую дякую